Let's return to the problem of guaranteeing
origin and path authentication. To guarantee these
properties there is a proposal to modify
the existing border gateway protocol to add signatures
to various parts of the route advertisement.
This proposal is sometimes called Secure BGP
or BGPSEC The proposal has two different
parts. The first part is an origin attestation,
which is a certificate that binds the IP
prefix to the organization that owns that prefix,
including the origin AS. This is sometimes also
called an address attestation. Now, this certificate must
be signed by a trusted party. That trusted
party might be, for example, a routing registry
or the organization that allocated that prefix to
that organization in the first place. The second
part of BGPSEC is what's called a path attestation which are a
set of signatures that accompany the AS path as it is advertised from
one AS to the next. Let's have a closer look at BGPSEC's
path attestation and the types of attacks that it can and cannot prevent.